hello friends oh my god we have a
whippet t-shirt
and a vote and a corn queen thank you
for making your corn queen
making me oh gosh you guys look so great
and i can see her feeling some
patriotism
this week it's election week
here it is it's upon us and we're gonna
get red white and drew
yeah thanks you guys i know everyone i
work with puns my name with everything
and i
love it i have to admit all right see if
you can spot the flags we've placed
around the set that's my little antique
one that
is on my home wall so i brought it into
work and
today is not the first time that i've
waved an american flag
no it's not and i just want to celebrate
the fact that we
are able to vote and i know it's
imperfect and underserved and
alienating at times and not on point or
solved or perfect in any way
but it is still ours and it's okay that
we have different views and experiences
and desires and
we focus so much on our differences to
the point where i think we're even
challenged to believe that we can
actually ever come together
but what if we could come together in an
honest and authentic way and be
ourselves without judgment when we cast
our vote
my deepest hope is that we stay calm and
somehow be good to each other regardless
this is a week where we express so much
let's be true to ourselves and
embrace the fact that even our own
values
today might be different than when we
were younger too
i know i've changed
still the same but different we change
and we grow and i just want to celebrate
the fact that this is what we do as a
country
we vote and even
if we vote differently we are still
doing the same act of voting itself ha
gotcha i found something we have in
common
and that common ground may seem naive
but i can't help it
i want us to all take care of each other
the best we can
and we'll look at how we're going to be
doing that all week long
you